so was anybody else not expecting Apple
to have an event the day before
Halloween and then call it scary fast
like this is unprecedented like I've
never I don't think in the history of at
least covering Apple things that
something like this has happened like
and it's in New York and it's late like
this is past my bedtime first of all I
just don't even know what to expect but
as soon as they said scary fast and then
they showed like the little finder logo
I was like M are we getting M3
it seems like just yesterday I got my
14in M2 Pro Max Macbook so now we're
already going to get an M I just I can't
even I'm so excited obviously I don't
know what's happening I know I am going
to New York to go to the event so before
I head to New York let's take a little
look at some rumors to see what we can
expect at the scary fast random event
day before Halloween and of course it is
a streaming event so I feel like this
event could could be really fun and
spooky cuz it does feel like they are
embracing the Halloween theme so I'm
wondering like should I bring a costume
like do I dress up I love Halloween and
I almost was like I don't think I can go
to this event because I need to be back
for trick-or treat either way I'm going
to the event Justine likes Halloween
that's what we're Gathering From the
intro of this video okay let's dive in
to what we can expect from scary fast so
here on Mac Rumors it says that Apple
has never hosted a nighttime event
before so there it is you heard it here
first they've never done this before
which is kind of so Random I just don't
even I can't even wrap my mind around
this so the scary fast event will be
focused on the Mac so they're saying
this is these are rumors the rumors have
been mixed about what we can expect at
the event but it sounds like we're going
to get the entire M3 chip lineup now I
do know previously I did go to New York
for another um MacBook event I believe
it was for the the 16in MacBook like
years ago so them doing events in New
York is not something new but the whole
nighttime thing so so strange so strange
but I'm here for it so first up the new
14-in and the 16-in MacBook Pro the
models were updated with the M2 Pro the
M2 Max chips so that was only in January
so yeah I guess it is kind of early for
an update but it's not unheard of for
Apple to refresh a Mac twice in a single
year in the rumors it's saying the base
M3 Pro chip will have 12 core CPU 18
core GPU with upgrades available for the
14 core and a 20 core GPU the bass M3
Max chip will have a 16 core GPU and a
32 core GPU with an option to upgrade to
4 40 core GPU now getting the 14-in
MacBook was by far the best decision
that I feel like I've ever made in my
entire life which maybe that's not
saying much about my entire life but for
me traveling so much again having this
14in has been so key the 16 in was just
a little bit too big and the performance
on this thing is so beyond impressive I
did get the 8 tbte so I'm hoping that
they have a bigger internal drive I
would get it for sure you you better
believe it because being able to work
directly off of this and not having to
have external drives it's so great it's
so amazing says there's a recent rumor
suggesting that the 14in 16-in MacBook
Pro will get more power efficient mini
LED displays so there's a chance we'll
also see some tweaks to display
performance if we get the M3 upgrade and
a new mini LED display the MacBook Pro
Models could have significant
improvements in their battery life which
yeah which would totally make sense
because especially if you are getting a
more power efficient display that will
help with the battery life as well now
the iMac is something that I feel
desperately did need an update I'm so
upset because we just got my dad the M1
silver MAC for Christmas or whenever I
don't even I'm not even sure if it was a
holiday I think we just said Dad you
need a new Mac and Me and my sister got
that for him so it looks like they are
going to be refreshing the 24-in iMac
because that's still using the M1 chip
which is kind of wild to think about if
anyone remembers this video where I
unboxed all of the colors still to this
date one of my favorite videos that I've
ever made so it looks like the iMac is
expected to get the updates and also the
13-in MacBook Pro is still using the M1
so that could definitely be a huge boost
in performance going from the M1 to the
M3 also do we even need the 13-in
MacBook Pro now because there's the
MacBook Air there's it's it's a really
confusing Mac lineup there's I don't I
think they might even just do away with
the MacBook Pro 13in because I feel like
the MacBook Air is so well I don't I
don't know anything I'm just speculating
and talking out loud and spewing my
thoughts live here for you saying there
won't be a noticeable change to the iMac
but it looks like maybe they'll tweak
the stand okay upgrade to Wi-Fi 6E is
likely as well as Bluetooth 5.3 the M3
iMac is reportedly being tested in
orange blue pink and silver finishes
okay I think they'll do some different
colors USBC accessories okay I need the
duo charger in USBC please because I'm
struggling now that the the only thing
that I need to bring the lightning cable
for is my Duo charger we need to update
that the Magic Mouse the magic Trackpad
the magic keyboard those are all still
USBC so maybe they'll just kind of drop
those in as the transition to Apple's
USBC continues so here for it and um of
course um if you don't have a USBC cable
I know where you can get one pink iustin
cables.com and of course they come in
pink so you know that's the key detail
there was also an article that says what
not to expect I love this it says Nope
what's not to expect at Apple scary fast
event uh M3 13-in MacBook Pro M3 13-in
and 15-in MacBook Air no MacBook Pro Mac
Studio Mac Mini no new iPads no iPhone
se4 no Vision Pro headsets no new
airpods lineup which H they're going to
have to do that soon because those
airpods Max are still
lightning and the last thing on this
list is no homepod Okay so scary fast I
feel like it's going to be focusing like
they said mostly on the 14in and 16-in
MacBook and possibly the iMac they have
to update the iMac they have to it's
it's it's an M1 it's so old it's like
put it in the retirement home so if you
guys want to watch the event it is
happening at 5:00 p.m. Pacific on Monday
October 30th which is still so great
because usually they do like Tuesday
events this is all so wild oh my
goodness I am so excited and I'm still
debating do I wear a costume if you guys
want to watch some more videos I'll put
them here on the end screen I'd love to
hear from you in the comments below what
do you think this event is going to be
about I mean I think we all know what
the event's going to be about so feel
free to leave a comment anyway